There's no doubt about it, few celebrities are more popular than Angelina Jolie.
Now, Forbes has labeled her as the most powerful actress on its Celebrity 100 List.
On top of starring in countless films ranging from drama flicks to animation,...
...she also has a side that we can all relate to.
After having a preventative double mastectomy...
...due to her increased risk for developing breast cancer,...
...the actress recently shared her experience with the world.
It's that type of down-to-earth confession that makes average folks gravitate towards her,...
...in essence, making her more personable.
According to Forbes editors, Jolie shows an "ability to shape a national conversation...
...while earning one of the highest paychecks in Hollywood."
With 33 million dollars in earnings, she ranked in at number 41 overall on the compilation.
Coming behind Jolie, the second most powerful actress is the young Jennifer Lawrence.
She got her big breakthrough in the 2012 hit film, "The Hunger Games,"...
...which took in 690 million dollars around the world.